Ờ
dù hiện tại thì như mình bảo là thỉnh
thoảng mình sẽ
livestream vào những cái giờ nó hơi
không theo một cái lịch cố định nào cả
bởi vì mình kiểu mình nghĩ là mình tiện
một hai tiếng vào đó thì mình sẽ học
đúng không ạ? Chúng ta học sẽ như thế.
Một là chúng ta có giờ cố định, hai là
chúng ta khi nào tiện. Nói chung là vẫn
thiên về cái việc mình khi nào tiện nhất
thì mình học đúng không ạ? Có gì mình
livestream lại thì vẫn sẽ có
vẫn có người xem lại mà nên không sao.
Ồ, xin chào bạn. Bạn người đầu tiên vừa
không biết rồi. Chắc là tối nay thì tối
nay chủ nhật thì chắc là vẫn sẽ có người
rảnh như mình. À tôi không nói không có
việc gì làm thì không đúng. Thực ra là
mình nghĩ ra gần đây mình đã nghĩ ra rất
nhiều thêm nhiều thứ nữa mà mình muốn
làm để vai code các thứ thứ nhưng mà
làm là một chuyện mình vẫn cần phải học
thêm nữa. Và mình nghĩ việc mình
livestream học thế này biết đâu biết đâu
truyền cảm hứng được cho những bạn nào
cần. À bấy ví dụ điển hình à mỗi lần
mình livestream này mình cảm thấy cũng
rất là bất ngờ khi mà có thêm nhiều
người mới vào server Discord của mình.
thì chứng tỏ chứng tỏ là à cũng có người
có nhu cầu cũng người tìm đến đúng không
ạ? Thì đơn giản là
à
mình ừ mình livestream những giờ dị này
có khi là chẳng có ai live trùng với
mình nói hay
em mất gốc rồi học cùng anh được không
ạ?
Ờ nếu mà để em học Java
mà từ đầu thì là không nên bởi vì cái
nếu mà em để ý ở trong a cái danh sách
trên kênh của anh thì anh có tạo một cái
mục là mục khóa học hồi trước để mỗi
trong playlist nhưng mà gần đây nó đẻ ra
cái mục là mục khóa học ấy thì
cái mục khóa học cost đấy thì mình để
cái này ở số 6 cơ nghĩa là nó là phải là
advance nó nâng cao.
nó chuyên sâu hơn. Vì cái này là mình
học là từ
từ duy của việc là mình từ ngôn ngữ khác
mình biết ngôn ngữ khác mình chuyển qua
ngôn ngữ này và thậm chí là mình còn
mạnh ở ngôn ngữ khác rồi cụ thể là PP
đấy mình đã đi làm rồi còn nếu mà em
muốn học gốc từ đầu thì thực ra anh
không dạy Java từ đầu anh là dân học về
ngôn ngữ lập trình là web PP HTML sẽ thì
em muốn học về web thực ra là ngôn ngữ
lập trình nào cũng n giống nhau thôi thì
em có thể học cái a playlist đầu tiên là
sẽ q out cơ nhưng mà học cái đấy có thể
học song song làm học một tí về web cũng
được đấy sau đó thì à em anh nghĩ là em
chỉ cần xem ba video đầu là em sẽ định
hình được là mình có phù hợp với cái ông
thầy này không rồi đấy bởi vì là mình
dạy mình sẽ thấy các bạn sẽ thấy một
buổi của mình hai tiếng nói hay gì đó kể
cả trên lớp luôn nhá là mình sẽ nói lý
thuyết tầm chỉ có 15 30 phút thôi. Còn
đâu chủ yếu là thực hành và chia sẻ thêm
nhiều cái khác nữa thì
đấy là một cách của mình học và cách
mình dạy luôn.
thì bạn thấy phù hợp hoặc thậm chí thậm
chí bởi vì kiến thức đấy bạn thấy không
đủ chẳng hạn bạn thể học thêm nhiều
video sau cũng là một cách hoặc là học
của song song của thầy khác bởi vì mình
nhớ hồi trước thầy à có bạn cũng chia sẻ
mình có tận ba thầy liền xong rồi xong
rồi à bạn ấy học của mình đầu tiên để có
truyền cảm hứng đã xong rồi bạn ấy học
chuyên sâu nâng cao hơn thì từ các thầy
khác nữa đấy nên là ừ Em có thể học của
anh nhưng mà không phải là playlist này.
Nếu mà giả sử em mới học về ngôn ngữ lập
trình, em còn là sinh viên thì không
nên. Còn nếu mà em đang đi làm rồi thì
có thể vào để ngồi chúng ta cùng ngồi
học ôn thêm những cái kiến thức bổ sung.
Đấy, bởi vì cái này nó sẽ không đi mạnh
vào cái phần
gọi là cốt lõi theo kiểu dạng là nó vẫn
có động vào base, nó động vào cái nền
nhưng mà mình thấy là nó sẽ thiên về cái
việc là
kiểu nó không dạy về cú pháp này, nó
không dạy về thế kiểu nên code thế nào
mà nó sẽ là
à không đúng nó dạy nên code thế nào nó
không dạy việc là code thế nào cho chạy
được mà lại dạy về code thế nào cho
clean hay vân vân gì á chẳng hạn.
Anh tiến tính chuyển sang Java hả anh? Ờ
không thực ra là mình học cái này. Cái
đầu tiên mình muốn ui không biết được
các bạn đ các bạn không biết được mình
đã ấp ủ học cái Java này từ ờ các bạn
hình dung nhá. Mình à mình học ở trên
trường xong rồi đi lại à xong rồi ở lại
dậy đúng không ạ? Ở lại dậy bởi vì mình
chuyên PP nên mình dạy mỗi PP thôi. Thì
hồi đấy là có một môn Java nữa nhưng
mình không dạy được. Đấy ngay tại thời
điểm đấy mình đã nghĩ là tại sao mình là
giảng viên dạy đáng ấy mình phải chuẩn
là là mình có thể dạy được hết tất cả
các môn để mà thể hiện nói chung là kiểu
mình bao quát được ý. Đấy, ngay tại thời
điểm đấy mình đã nghĩ là chắc chắn là
mình về sau mình sẽ học Java để mình à
mình
để mà nói có thể dậy nó khó lắm. Chuẩn
là với mình quan điểm nhá, dạy để làm
được khác với dạy thực sự hiểu để dạy
bởi vì nó na ná giống như là hồi trước
có cái a tự nhiên cái này cứ hơi lan man
một tí nhưng mà tôi thấy là nó cũng có
một cái hay ý. Đấy, đó là hồi trước tôi
lại nhớ một cái chủ đề ở trên Redit, nó
là có một cái khái niệm đó là
explain like I am fine, tức là hãy giải
thích sao cho tao như một đứa trẻ 5
tuổi. Đấy, kiểu thế. Tức là
để mà ông dạy được một cái gì đó, ông
phải nói cho một đứa thậm chí là không
phải biết công nguyện ông tin, thậm chí
là như một đứa trẻ ấ nó vẫn có thể hiểu
được cái kiểu quy luật hay mọi thứ của
nó. nghe nó rất là khó đúng không? Nhưng
mà để mà để mà ông lên cái ngưỡng là ông
thể nói cho người khác hiểu được như thế
thì mới chuẩn là với tôi thấy là kiểu
kiểu lý tưởng nhất ấy là dạy được. Còn
nếu mà không thì chỉ cầm tay chỉ việc và
sẽ thiên về việc là chỉ đâu đánh đấy hay
gì đó. Tức là chỉ là sẽ gần như là tướng
và lính kiểu thế cầm tay à chỉ đâu đành
đó đúng không? Nhưng mà lính thì sẽ
không bao giờ khó lên làm tướng nếu mà
không được đào tạo hơn, không được học
chiến lược hay vân vân. Ông có hình dung
không? Nghĩa là đấy kiểu thế nghĩa là
một một à hệ lại liên quan câu chuyện
giống như là khi ông đi làm sẽ có rất
nhiều sếp nó giống như boss nó giống như
boss à có boss v leader chắc là tôi từng
nói với ông khái niệm đấy đây kiểu như
này này là người sếp sẽ luôn là người
chỉ việc thôi chỉ là mày phải làm vớiz
thôi thực sự là không hề không hề cho
ông thêm kiến thức ông tự mình thêm kiến
thức chứ người đấy không cù cung cấp cho
ông thên kiến thức. Đấy, còn người
leader, người lãnh đạo chuẩn thì là
người có thể tiên phong, người đi cùng
và có thể hướng đến. Và thậm chí là có
cái câu của Anonymus à đó là
chuẩn là nó sẽ phải tạo ra được các
leader khác nữa. Nghĩa là kiểu
mình à chia sẻ thêm kinh nghiệm, mình
chia sẻ thêm mọi thứ để khiến cho những
người khác sẽ có sẽ có cơ hội để trở
thành người kiểu tốt hơn và kiểu có
những vị trí về sau giống mình. Đấy,
tránh cái việc là mình chỉ ở cấp trên,
mình ở bề trên mình áp xuống và thậm chí
ông nào mà phản lại thì mình đuổi hoặc
gì đó đúng không ạ? Thì rõ ràng là môi
trường này môi trường không phù hợp để
mình phát triển. Đấy, tôi nói hơi lan
man nhưng mà nó vẫn có một cái gì đó
đúng không ạ?
Thì uầy tự nhiên đang nói chuyển sang
đang từ hỏi một câu thì nhảy sang cái
này. Nhưng đại khái tôi không hẳn là
chuyển sang Java mà tôi học Java muốn
học Java từ lâu và càng về sau càng cùng
cố thêm là tôi học chuyên sâu. Tôi làm
chuyên sâu thêm về PP tôi thấy có rất
nhiều vấn đề phát sinh đặc biệt liên
quan về button design button và
tôi muốn chuyên sâu về back end. Thực sự
đến bây giờ tuy r là tôi đã gần đây tôi
động fan nhiều hơn nhá là tôi may mà cảm
ơn ai một lần nữa cảm ơn ai đã ngồi cho
tôi kiểu được vai code để ngồi gọi là
sửa giao diện các thứ xịn m màu mè hồi
trước CF các thứ hơi kém hơ không quan
tâm thì nó kém ý đấy nhưng mà tôi thật
sự về sau vẫn muốn chuyên sâu về back
end thì về thứ nhất là ngôn ngữ lập
trình thứ hai về database thì rõ ràng là
PP P không được thiên về việc xử lý
những bài toán rất là lớn và ở những
công ty lớn thì không dùng PP nên là về
sau tôi sẽ thứ nhất là tôi phải học về
lean architect các thứ thứ đúng không?
Thứ hai là để về sau mình không ngại một
ngôn ngữ lập trình nào chưa chắc là Java
mình có thể về sau Gan hay gì đó nhưng
kiểu gì nó vẫn có một cái nền tảng nhất
định là hướng đối tượng đúng không
button các thứ nó vẫn giống nhau thôi
nên là học Java nó là cái kiểu cái nền
để mà mình có thể học ngôn ngữ khác chứ
không phải là tôi sẽ chuyển sang Java vì
rõ ràng bây giờ tôi làm gì có dự án Java
nào để mà thực hành đâu đấy nhưng mà
trong cái khóa học trăm mành này này tôi
sẽ tôi sẽ muốn sẽ làm sau đó đấy.
đây th kiểu thế bởi vì thực sự để mà nói
nhá tôi không chê người khác về kiến
thức nhưng tôi khẳng định luôn là không
phải người thầy nào ở bên ngoài kia kể
cả đi đi dạy ở trung tâm hay dạy đại học
không phải thầy nào cũng có tâm đấy nên
là sẽ mang giống kiểu thợ dậy hơn không
thầy không phải thầy nào bởi vì nói
thẳng luôn có nhiều thầy còn kiểu vì cái
tôi bản thân kiểu muốn đèn ép sinh viên
muốn a nói thẳng luôn là muốn có một tí
từ sinh viên các thứ rất nhiều vấn đề
đúng không ạ rất nhiều vấn đề đấy không
phải thầy nào cũng kiểu thực sự là kiểu
xát xao sinh viên có người thì bảo với
tôi là thầy làm thế để sinh viên không ỷ
lại cũng có thể đúng nhưng tôi đã từng
chia sẻ một câu chuyện của tôi và bạn
tôi đó là cóòn những người thầy khiến
cho bạn đấy hoặc là thậm chí tôi cũng
từng rất ghét người như thế may là tôi
đi làm rồi Nên tôi kẻo biết được à trong
ngành này có người này người kia. Nhưng
mà rõ ràng có những sinh viên ở trên
trường người ta mới ngồi trên ghế nhà
trường không được tiếp xúc mấy. Xong rồi
cái người mình tiếp xúc nhiều nhất là
thầy của mình ở trong ngành này đúng
không ạ? Thì người thầy đấy người ta
không phục, người ta không thích thì
người ta sẽ không baoờ muốn trở thành
người như thế. người ta sẽ không theo
ngành này. Đấy thì rõ ràng là thế là một
cái kiểu tự nhiên biến thành cái viết
nhơ ở trong ngành đúng không ạ?
lại dùng bên thứ ba dậy ạ. Tự tổ chức là
phức tạp hay sao? À cái việc cái trang
hồi trước mình có cái trang ấy thế bạn
còn biết cả trang blog của mình ờ hồi đ
hồi đấy là hồi hồi đầu mình viết block
ấy mình nhớ là từ 52 53 gì đấy phải mình
không nhớ chính xác lắm giờ chắc phải
xem lại. Đại khái là hồi đấy là mình
dồng tạm cái trang nhanh để mà lên nhanh
thôi. Vì hồi đấy là bây giờ bảo code từ
đầu nó hơi mất công. Kết hợp phải tìm
hiểu. Thực ra là mình cũng không quan
trọng cái đấy lắm vì rõ ràng là mình lúc
đấy chỉ cần có một nơi để đăng lên. Và
thực ra là hồi đấy mình đăng theo kiểu
dạng là muốn tự sự hơn là để mang thức
tính là học thuật hay chia sẻ. Thế nên
là các bạn thấy là mình đến bây giờ mình
cũng vẫn không viết đều lâu lắm không
viết.
cái việc là mình không a không chia sẻ
cho các bạn cái trang blog đấy. Bây giờ
mình hoạt động vẫn là sôi nổi trên trang
fanpage Facebook lẫn cả à fanpage gần
đây còn ít cơ. Chắc là bây giờ sôi nổi
nhất ở trên server Discord bởi vì mình
thấy là trên server Discord là mọi người
có tương tác trên đấy nhiều nhất. Đấy
thì mình làm mình mình làm ở nơi nào mà
tương tác được mọi người nhiều thôi để
mình hiểu được mọi người thôi đúng không
ạ? Còn block thì nó có một tí nhá. Mang
thiên hướng là tuy là mấy ông bình luận
ở đấy được đúng không? Nhưng mang thiên
hướng một tí là kiểu hơi dẫn dắt dư
luận. À mấy ông biết khái niệm đấy
không? Tức là kiểu ông đăng ở trên xong
rồi
sẽ có một tràng xong mới đến cái phần
bình luận của ông mà đúng không? Thì rõ
ràng là ông sẽ bị dắt một tí nữa đấy. Và
rất ít người kéo xuống dưới để mà tranh
luận. Nên thành ra là kiểu tôi sẽ có một
cái gì đó ở trên đấy nó tương tác không
phải là hai chiều. Đấy, tương tác hai
chiều ở đây vẫn là server Discord hoặc
là nhóm Facebook nhưng mà tôi không ngại
việc tạo hẳn cái nhóm rồi quản lý đấy á.
thì tôi đã từng quản lý nhóm và
nói chung là ờ
tôi thấy là hiện tại bên server Discord
hiện tại vẫn vẻ đang ổn đấy chưa biết
sau này thế nào và thực ra tôi cũng
không nếu nếu biết đâu về sau mình nồn
nổi hơn mình nổi tiếng hơn thì mình còn
không thời gian nữa mình sẽ phải nhờ
người khác quản lý à tôi hơi ngại cái
điều đề điều đấy tôi không muốn mình cực
kỳ nổi hay là kiểu có quá nhiều đông
người vào khiến nó loãng một cái gì Đó,
nếu mà giả sử về sau mà server này nó
đông hơn, ví dụ bây giờ 1000 người nhưng
thực ra là chỉ có tầm à cứ cho 100 đi
100 là cao thôi nhá. 100 người tương tác
thường xuyên thì còn đỡ. Hiện tại mấy
thấy các bạn thấy là tin nhắn nó vẫn
chưa bị trôi đúng không ạ? Nếu về sau
đông hơn thì chắc là tôi sẽ mở nhóm
Facebook để cho hạn chế bị trôi, mọi
người có thể đọc được những cái gì nó
chất hơn. Đấy, dự định tôi là thế.
Còn về vlog thì
như mình chia sẻ mình không có quá nhiều
kiến thức để mà mình chia sẻ cho các bạn
quá kiểu chi tiết blog nó phải chiêm
nghiệm, nó phải đúc kết nó nào giống như
ở ông viết sách ấy. Theo tôi là thế.
nghĩa là nó phải cực kỳ cô đọng chứ nếu
mà mình chỉ viết kiểu tự sự toàn mạn thì
nó là block theo kiểu
nó sẽ không mang thiên hướng về chia sẻ
nữa mà kiểu tâm sự hơn.
Anh có tự tin giao tiếp phỏng vấn bằng
tiếng Anh không ạ? Thực ra là ông thấy
cái video gần nhất tôi đăng đó là tôi
chính xác là tôi phỏng vấn trả lời phỏng
vấn của một bên và tôi phải nói song ngữ
bởi vì tôi không nói hoàn toàn bằng
tiếng Anh được vì mình quen giao tiếp
anh liên tục đâu. Đấy
nhưng mà tôi tôi tự tôi được cái tôi rất
là tự tin. Tôi biết được ưu nhược của
mình là gì và tôi khá là tự tin và khả
năng của mình đến đâu. Về việc nói
chuyện tiếng Anh bình thường thì tôi vẫn
nói được. Kể cả hôm trước phỏng vấn bằng
tiếng Anh tôi vẫn nói được. Đấy chẳng
qua là tôi không tự tin việc mình nó rất
là hay, nói rất là tốt hay có gì gì đó.
Đặc biệt là mình chưa có luyện cái việc
là âm điệu à cái thần thái, phong cách
gì thế đó. Bởi vì là mình tính a là tôi
mới chỉ có xem phim nghe nhạc là nhiều
chứ thực ra là thực hành ít lắm cũng
chưa thi một cái chứng chỉ tiếng Anh nào
vào.
Đợi tôi một tí tôi xem tí nhắn
Ờ thì hôm qua nhưng bạn thấy thật ra bạn
thấy tiêu đề nó bị lạp với cái hôm qua
đúng không ạ? Bởi vì hôm qua chúng ta
chưa học được cái gì cả. Rất xin lỗi các
bạn. Hôm hôm qua mình mới a ơ
đúng rồi mình định bảo làm
cái này tổng hợp thành cái ảnh nhưng mà
mình quên mất là hôm qua chưa học để
mình biết được cô đọng là một cái ảnh nó
trông nên trông như thế nào để cho nó
tổng hợp thông tin. Đây mình hôm nay
mình sẽ bắt đầu học và hôm nay để bù cho
cả hôm qua nữa hôm nay mình sẽ cứ cho là
hôm nay buổi thứ sáu nhá. Thì tí mình sẽ
soạn luôn cả bài buổi thứ sáu để mình sẽ
học cả buổi bài thứ năm thứ sáu. Còn hôm
qua chỉ bài ôn lại thôi.
rồi. Không biết lần này nó sẽ à đâu cái
này gọi không phải reset mà restart à.
Đây không biết lần này nó sẽ có thêm cái
cập nhật cái gì.
dùng AI để viết zoom nữa. Đúng mình nên
thì nó kiểu giống kiểu cá nhân hóa thôi
đúng không? Nhìn thấy hay mà.
Đây, đợi mình tí, mình muốn xem cái trên
lock của nó nó sẽ thêm cái gì. Ừ, cải
thiện mỗi cái này. Thế mà bị thật à cải
thiện để cho long conversion. Ok. Kiểu
cải thiện thêm gì đó. Ok.
Xin chào bạn. À
bạn này có hoạt động thời
bé yêu group X Group không?
Thôi không biết nhóm đấy. Nay anh học
sớm thể à. Tiện tiện người yêu chưa qua
chơi đi chơi thì mình tranh đủ học thôi
ạ. Ờ
các file ơ cái này postit rồi mà đúng
không?
Hôm qua cập nhật rồi mà nhỉ? Đúng không?
Cập nhật rồi thêm cái gì gì đó rồi đúng
không?
Hôm qua thêm rồi mà. Hay đâu? Xem lại
nào.
rồi mình sẽ soạn ra một cái doc. Đây các
bạn thấy là tham khảo mình sẽ có thêm
dog xong rồi có thêm cả ảnh nữa rất xịn
đúng không ạ? Đấy rất chuyên nghiệp dần
dần dần biết đâu về sau tôi làm thêm quả
code hoặc là thực ra là có những cái
tool có sẵn rồi mình sẽ biến cái này
thành slide kiểu power point. Đấy, hồi
trước là tôi từng dạy mấy ông thì mấy
ông thấy là tôi chẳng dùng PowerPoint gì
cả đúng không ạ? Nó không chuyên nghiệp.
Đúng, nó vẫn không hề chuyên nghiệp.
Đấy, để tôi sẽ làm quả đấy luôn. Hoàn
thành. Bạn muốn bắt đầu với sáu luôn
không?
À đợi tí tôi bảo thằng này soạn luôn.
Dựa
Tôi muốn
dựa vào file này tạo
và
ngày 6.
đâu sao?
à cái link cái link GHub này đúng không?
À cái này là đây là bạn sinh viên của
tôi. Tôi nhờ bạn đấy tạo cái a tạo cái
repo lúc đầu bởi vì lúc đầu là tôi nhờ
bạn ấy dạy tôi Java mà bạn ấy chuyên về
Java thì dạy nhờ nhờ bạn ấy tạo Ripo dạy
tôi buổi một rồi tôi thấy hay quá là từ
đấy tôi nghĩ là tôi có kiểu háo hứng hơn
tôi muốn học nhiều hơn và tôi muốn
livestream về mấy ông học cùng nữa vì
bạn ấy cũng không thường xuyên để mà
hàng ngày học cùng mình được kiểu mình
tự học và có dùng AI hay mọi thứ như này
mình chủ động mình vẫn tiện hơn đúng
không
Đấy. Thế nên là tôi nhờ bạn ấy tạo lúc
đầu thôi. Và bạn ấy vẫn có xem video của
tôi và vẫn kiểu sẽ góp ý các thứ các
thứ. Và tôi cũng muốn là mấy ông nếu có
thể thì gọi là khái niệm double check à
tức là ngồi kiểm tra lại xem cùng tôi
xem có vấn đề gì không. Ngồi góp ý ngồi
học cùng đúng không ạ?
sáu rồi sau cái này tên là Animal này.
object class à ok. Uầy
không nhưng mà thực ra là tôi không cần
file class lắm. Tôi không muốn có file
class ở đây. Chỉ muốn có file
ơ hình như vừa rồi mình xóa gì sai sai
phải. Đợi tí. À đâu đúng mà.
Sao file ja có một file Java mà tạo được
nhiều file class thế á?
file class à
Ý ông là sao? Nghĩa là dùng cái à vào
thẳng code project chứ không phải ngồi
học này á.
sẽ có mà trong này mấy ông thấy là kiểu
gì về sau cũng sẽ có ngồi code không có
chỉ có ngồi xuông này đâu. Học đây đặt
tảm các thứ đấy. Sau ngày 25 đúng không?
Cứ cho là 1 tháng đúng không? Th thực ra
đấy còn chưa tính việc thỉnh thoạc tôi
nghỉ bất chợt nữa đấy. Mình sẽ có dự án
các thứ thứ lúc đấy tôi ngồi code cho
mấy ông xem được không ạ? Ok tạm chốt
thi nhá. Còn à
muốn cái ở đây nó cái này nó nên ngắn
gọn xúc tích thôi. Không nên có quá
nhiều file.
Ok. Ờ à không mình không nên xem doc
mình nên xem code trước. Doc tính sau
đấy code dễ hiểu như kiểu tôi lại nhớ
cái câu của anh em lập trình hay nói với
nhau kiểu đừng có giải thích nhiều. Show
me your code đúng không? Anh được code
của máy đây. Đấy
thỉnh thoảng tôi bây giờ tôi không phải
thỉnh thoảng tôi bắn tiếng Anh đâu nhá
mà nó chỉ là có những cái tôi nghĩa là
nó là me me à mim à. Đấy cái có nhiều
cái là tôi sẽ và tôi cũng muốn một tí
gọi là thực hành tiếng Anh với mấy ông
cứ cho là thế đi chứ bình thường ngoài
tôi không bằn tiếng Anh đâu.
Cách cũ không dùng generic nguy hiểm
không chỉ định kiểu so kháng thêm số vào
complier không báo lỗi. À ui cái lỗi này
vẫn vẫn đôi khi vẫn phải quay lại một tí
với PP. PP mảng chứa bất kỳ cái gì được
mà chứa mảng mà chứa mọi thứ cũng được
trong đấy. Đấy khá là nguy hiểm đúng
không ạ?
khai báo này giống script một tí nhở. À
đương nhiên là có khi script sinh sau mà
tôi nhớ hình như là về sau tôi mới nghe
script chắc là script sinh sau thì đó là
script sẽ học từ cái thằng này đúng
không ạ? Là để cho code ra script nó
chặc chẽ hơn đúng không ạ? Đấy. Đấy. T
safety. Ok. Bao lỗi hợp lý
không có nép kiểu class tổng quát
box có thể chữ bất kỳ kiểu dữ liệu gì.
Ơ đợi tí. Array này,
elite này.
đang chưa hiểu cái này lắm.
sẽ so sánh đây. Tôi sẽ tạm đánh dấu lại
box à iit này
đúng không ạ? P box này
báo ở dưới. Ok. Làm tôi cứ tưởng là nó
là một cái kiểu mới.
Ừ. Có khi cái này nhược điểm khi mà đọc
trong cái Java đúng không? Đọc trong
class này nó sẽ tách tách file ra tránh
việc là mình kiểu không hiểu đúng không?
À đây
khai báo kiểu à đúng rồi khai báo kiểu
này giống kiểu get set một cái gì đó
đúng không? Ok
cũng hay khai báo kiểu này à t value
t này là gì nhỉ?
À tham số kiểu có thể đặt tên bất kỳ
đúng không? Time này
element key value gì đó. Ồ thường ở
trong
thường ở trong a PP đúng không? thì mình
sẽ không dùng t bao giờ mấy mình sẽ dùng
ở mình một được ghi thẳng là key type
key value hay gì gì đó value gì đó
rồi
hàm tổng quát
>> chị
ra em cún này ngoan hơn á em cún nếu mấy
ông xem video tôi á từ thời đầu đi hồi
đấy là tôi còn ở nhà khác xong rồi tôi
cũng có nuôi một em cún nhưng em đấy là
phốc em đấy rất là đánh dùng từ đánh đá
nó cũng không đúng vì nó con trai sẽ
dùng từ như này rất là kiểu
khó dạy kiểu thế khó nó còn em này rất
là ngoan em dễ dạy ngoan hiền chắc một
phần em này con cái nữa
Không, tôi chưa mua nhà đâu. Ui ông ơi,
bây giờ mình còn đang đi làm thuê
>> vốn còn chưa không có sẵn tự lực cánh
sinh ngay từ đầu. Nghĩa là nghĩa là đúng
nghĩa đúng nghĩa là bố mẹ không có sẵn
nhà nên là tôi vẫn đang đi làm thu vẫn
đang đi thuê nhà ấy. Ở Hà Nội thì tôi
cũng chưa biết được khi nào sẽ mua được
nhà. Có thể là mua nhà xã hội hay gì đó
>> nhưng mà thực ra là mình cũng quá cái
gì nhỉ? Ba cái điều kiện rồi. Nghĩa là
mức lương của mình nó ở cái đoạn mà
không phải đủ để mua nhà ở xã hội nhưng
mà cũng không đủ để mua nhà vì rõ ràng
là
quê á tôi tôi quê gốc thì là quảng trị.
Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ không hẳn về đấy vì
rõ ràng là thường người ở quê tôi sẽ đi
tỉnh khác để mà sinh sống để mà kiêm
sống. Đấy. Còn à Quế ngoại thì ở Hà ở
Linh Đàm là ở Hà Nội đúng không ạ? Nên
là tôi thường là tết tôi sẽ không có quê
để về. Không giống các bạn lắm đấy. Nên
là nó sẽ không có cái trường hợp với quê
mà sẽ khái niệm đi ra một cái tỉnh nào
đó để ở chứ không khái niệm về quê nữa.
Ông hiểu gì? Tôi đấy. À biết rồi thì
cũng có cách thứ ba là bây giờ lấy vợ
rồi về quê vợ.
Hoặ thậm chí là mấy vợ vợ có sẵn nhà
mình về kiểu chạn vương chui chạn đấy
hẳn là tôi nghĩ là trong trường hợp của
tôi thì vẫn à không phải bế tắc hay là
kiểu gì nó tiêu cực hay là kiểu khổ hay
gì đó tôi cảm thấy là đang đủ sống và
đang rất là thoải mái chẳng qua là nó
không
với nhiều người là sẽ
mình chưa ăn cư, chưa lập nghiệp các thứ
đúng không? Đấy nên thật ra khái niệm ăn
cư của tôi thực ra hình như tôi cũng
từng chia sẻ mấy ông rồi. Ăn cư ra nó sẽ
không khái niệm là ăn cư là phải là có
có nhà ăn cư. Theo tôi vẫn là hiểu là có
một cái máy ấm
nghiệp ở Đấy Á. Thực ra cũng khó bởi vì
bây giờ tính ra thì bây giờ một là ở Hà
Nội, hai là ở Đà Nẵng hoặc là thành phố
Hồ Chí Minh thì cái nghề IT này nó mới
gọi là triển vọng. Còn bây giờ đi bất kỳ
tỉnh khác thì trừ khi ông làm ông xin
được việc làm remote, làm online còn
thậm chí ông phải sang nước ngoài gì đó.
Nếu không thì tự nhiên mình lại khiến
cho công việc mình khó khăn hơn đúng
không ạ? Hoặc là phải chuyển ngánh.
Chuyển ngành thì
ngành bây giờ nếu mà tôi mà có chuyển
ngành thì tôi không hẳn là có ý định
kinh doanh lắm thì chắc là tôi đi dạy mà
tôi đi dạy chắc là tôi vẫn dạy cái thế
mạnh của mình là dạy tin học chẳng hạn
dạy công tin thì về quê thì tính ra nó
lại không gọn là như nào nhỉ ví dụ một
cái điển hình nhá
à năm ngoái là ờ Bộ Giáo dục vừa mới
thay đổi cái quy chế thi là môn
Môn thi tốt nghiệp đại học có thể à môn
thi tốt nghiệp để đỗ vào đại học.
Nghĩa là thi đại học ấy thì bây giờ có
thêm môn nữa là môn tin học. Đấy có biết
cả nước được bao nhiêu người a thiin học
không? Đấy cho dù nó có kiểu rõ ràng là
anh em mình vẫn kiểu có thể ngồi chơi
game nhiều. Chắc chắn là game game thủ
giờ nhiều hơn thời trước của tôi luôn
đúng không? Nếu không biết tỉ lệ bao
nhiêu người chọn môn tin học không? Nó
còn thấp hơn cả môn công nghệ cái gì đó.
Tôi không nhớ cụ thể cái môn đấy lắm
nhưng mà tôi nhớ nó là môn kiểu na dầu
công nghệ. Tức là ở các tỉnh các thứ
người ta vẫn dạy không hẳn dạy về nhiều
về tin và không ai tự tin. Và khoản là
có thể thi vào mónn tin. Cho dù rõ ràng
là mình có thể dùng máy tính bây giờ
nhiều hơn rất nhiều đúng không? Mình
thạo dùng công tin, mình dùng AI, mình
dùng mạng xã hội hay vân vân vân các thứ
mình hạo hơn rồi. Nhưng mà tự nhiên bây
giờ mình có thêm một cánh cổng nữa và
thi bằng tin học thì mình cũng không tự
tin lắm. Môn tin học tôi nhớ là gần như
thấp nhất đấy. Tỉ lệ thấp nhất ấy. Đấy
thì rõ ràng là tin học không hề được
trọng dụng lắm
dạy thêm tín học hay gì đó. Nhưng mà
mình nghĩ là nó vẫn là xu thế tương lai
thôi bởi vì là nó thay đổi là thay đổi
năm ngoái nhưng mà mình sẽ cập nhật dần
ngay từ hồi lớp 10. Nghĩa là nó sẽ không
phải thay đổi lớp mỗi lớp 12 mà sẽ kiểu
phổ cập lại luôn cả kiến thức của lớp
10, lớp 11, lớp 12. Thì rõ ràng là những
cái bạn mà xác định là thi môn tin học
thì người ta sẽ học từ lớp 10. Đấy. Thì
2 năm nữa thì mình sẽ xem là cái thị
trường cái mọi thứ nó có thiên hướng về
xuôi về bên môn tin học không. Mà rõ
ràng là bây giờ rõ ràng là các bạn thấy
thi vào ngành IT ngành công nghệ thông
tin vẫn rất đông đúng không ạ? Nhưng mà
mọi người không chọn môn tin học, mọi
người vẫn chọn những cái môn mà họ đã ôn
sẵn rồi. Đó là môn toàn lý hóa hay gì gì
đó. Đấy,
bẻ đôi cũng chịu. Đúng. Thực sự là kiểu
có nhiều người mà chỉ cần bởi vì mình
vẫn thấy thiên hướng đó là người nào mà
không học công nghệ thông tin người ta
là khá là ngại rất là ngại. Tỷ lệ mình
gặp người công nghệ đ kiểu không phải
ngành công nghệ thông tin ấy mình chỉ
cần nói về việc là bây giờ dùng AI đi
người ta đã ngại rồi. Đấy kiểu thế nghĩa
là người ta cứ ngại cái gì thay đổi. Mà
rõ ràng công nghệ thông tin là như hôm
trước mình phân tích là không ngại thay
đổi, mình phải mở thoáng cái đầu lên chứ
nếu mà ngại ngại một cái gì đó không
theo được ngành này. Thật không theo
được ngành này. Và đúng có những người
mình quen cũng học công nguyện pin nhá.
Mình chỉ đơn giản họ đang dùng VS code
thôi nhá. Mình bảo bạn ấy cài
antigravity hay là Cor gì đó dùng AI
khác đi. Bạn ấy cũng ngại, bạn không
cải, bạn ấy có biết chat GVT nhá, bạn
chỉ hỏi chat GVT thôi. Xong rồi tôi bảo
chat cho GVT bây giờ hỗ trợ code tệ lắm,
mình nhảy sang cái ai khác đi. Bạn ấy
cũng ngại đấy. Kiểu thế. Thực sự thì ừ
nó tự làm cho mình trở ngại thôi. Đôi
khi là bài toàn lớn nhất lại là mình
không vượt qua được cái bóng. Dùng từ
cái bóng cũng đúng. Mình chưa là cái gì
để tạo ra cái bóng cả. Mình không vượt
qua được cái trở ngại lớn nhất là cái tư
duy của mình, cái giếng của mình. Mình
nói thế không phải là công kích bất kỳ
ai dạ chúng ta nhưng mà ai chúng ta sẽ
có một cái giếng riêng đúng không ạ?
Tùy cái giếng của người nào to thế nào.
Đấy,
lý thuyết xong tưởng tượng ra áp dụng nó
vô nhà mình thế nào, tính tiền thu nhập
gia đình, chi tiêu thứ các thứ để lên
sâu cũng không ngay. Đúng nghĩa là hồi
trước là mình làm mấy cái dự án P
project cá nhân thì cũng thường ấy thên
hướng là mình nghĩ xem là mọi thứ xung
quanh có thể dự công nghệ thông tin mọi
thứ như nào nhưng mà đấy là nói về việc
là mình là người tham học và chủ động
nhưng nó phải đi kèm với xung quanh có
tạo nên môi trường cho mình được như thế
không. Ví dụ giả sử bạn muốn học cái
ngin ví dụ nhá mình như mình vừa nói
luôn là năm vừa rồi mình nhớ là có một
tỉnh mà cả tỉnh đấy có một bạn thiin học
thôi. Nghĩa là chỉ là toàn bộ mọi thứ
môi trường xung quanh đâu có ủng hộ đâu
đúng không ạ? Không biết được là có ủng
hộ bạn ấy hết sức không nhưng mà chắc
chắn là không hể tạo một cái môi trường
tốt để bạn ấy học còn không biết được là
bạn ấy tự học hay là học ở trên trường.
Ông hình dung không? Nếu mà giả sử học
trên trường có một thầy dạy cho một trò
n khó đúng không? Đấy ông ông hiểu tôi
không? Nghĩa là
cái tuy là mình đang thay đổi dần nhưng
mà nó vẫn chỉ là thay đổi dần thôi. Và
bây giờ mình về đấy ừ có thể tôi sẽ tin
phong. Tôi sẽ đến gõ cửa từng nhà để mà
kiểu thay vì kiểu hồi trước là kiểu các
thầy đến gõ cửa từng nhà giống kiểu cứ
nói trên vùng núi đi là kiểu để mà xin
con đi học chữ đúng không? sinh con đi
học IT sinh con đi học kiểu gõ gõ máy
kiểu thế mà thực ra là ngành dậy này
cũng khó nữa vì các bạn thấy là ngành
công nghệ tin này bây giờ bị bão hòa phả
dùng từ bão hòa tức là nó không còn hot,
nó không còn nổi, nó không còn kiểu săn
đón à nhân viên nữa. Bây giờ Sa Hải cũng
nhiều rồi vân vân vân vân tỉ lệ thất
nghiệp cũng cao đấy. Thế nên là không
đảm bảo một cái đầu ra để mà mình háo
hứng cái việc là em cứ học đi kiểu gì sẽ
có việc làm hay mọi thứ đúng không? Hồi
trước thì mình còn nói là ngành công em
tin này là chỉ cần giỏi là sẽ được tuyển
không cần phải có người quen, không cần
phải đi chạy chọt đúng không? Còn bây
giờ thì chưa chắc nhá. Giờ nó khó hơn
nhiều rồi. Đôi khi có người quen là một
lợi thế. Lợi thế ở đây không phải lợi
thế là người quen giới thiệu vào đâu
nhá. Ngoài lợi thế này người quen ở
trong công ty biết được công ty có tuyển
hay là công ty đấy cái thằng này nó sắp
bị đuổi vân vân mách cho mình chứ bây
giờ ông lên mấy cái à trang tuyển dụng
ấy không đăng mấy đâu và đăng theo kiểu
là ông sẽ bị vào cái danh sách hàng chờ
hạn danh sách kiểu người ta sẽ không
người ta lọc ấy. Đấy ông sẽ có thể CV
ông đủ tốt à không đủ tốt nhưng mà trình
độ ông đủ tốt nhưng mà người ta lướt mất
là mất đúng không ạ?
Ôi tàn mạn hơi dài lại quay lại không
ngồi tản mạn tiếng mất. Ok
tống quát
cái hay này kiểu tạo mảng nó cách ngắn
hơn của cái này đúng không? Hai cái chắc
là một nhỉ?
Ừ
ừ tôi nghĩ hai cái là một nhưng mà array
list khác với chắc là phải khác với
array nhỉ đúng không?
array list PS array tôi cứ note cứ đánh
dấu lại đã
có hàm print array à hay là nó mình ghi
ở dưới đây đây lừa
tỉnh lắm
print list. Chắc chắn là quả này tôi tin
là quả lửa. Không có một cái hàm kiểu
kiểu như này đúng không ạ?
nhận number và
Chỉ chấp nhận number và các class con. Ừ
đúng kiểu cái này số th số. Ok. Cái này
tôi hiểu
cái này à cái này generic chung chứ nó
không liên quan đến array nhở. Nó không
nhắc về array nữa. Ok. Cái này thì dễ
hiểu mà không sao. Đại diện kiểu không
xác định
cái này là hỏi chấm là chấp nhận list
của bất kỳ kiểu nào. Ồ chỉ đọc được
không thêm được phần tử mới. Ok
dùng cái hàm for này đúng không? For này
giống kiểu for x của bên
PP. Thì cái này dùng
đợi tí có điện thoại của anh.
đây khai báo kiểu hay phết. Biết cẩn
thnh trông rõ ràng, dễ hiểu thật kiểu gì
nó kiểu ý tôi dễ hiểu ở đây là ngoài
việc code dễ hiểu ra là cái a cái phần
mềm gõ code ấy nó cũng sẽ dễ hiểu để mà
gợi ý ra là cái này đang báo lộ sai gì
đó kiểu dữ liệu mà đúng không? Nó tường
minh ấy.
Mấy không biết từ tường minh không? Tôi
thấy từng minh từng minh là một từ rất
là hay để nó thể hiện việc nó rõ ràng nó
kiểu nó xy kiểu minh bạch hay kiểu thế.
Cái từ tiếng tiếng Anh của nó thì nó sẽ
dễ hơn nó là transparent à
ờ tôi nhớ transparent gì đó kiểu trong
suốt à minh bạch rõ ràng cái thứ thừ
tương minh
từ minh là hình như là từ đấy từ Hán
Việt thì phải.
Ờ chấp nhận list của bất kỳ kiểu nào
xong rồi mình sẽ kiểu đây sẽ không khai
báo kiểu T nữa. Khai báo kiểu nó object.
Ok.
này qua rồi. Bing nếu mà bình thường mà
chứa bờ bãi chỉ chứa string đúng
ship có đúng script luôn này. Rồi so
sánh với cả JavaScript nhá. Ok cũng xị
nào. Lưu ý quan trọng.
Complier sẽ xóa tất cả thông tin generic
sau khi compl
học thì thầy báo anh live anh học tốt
nhé anh tắm cái cũng vào việc. Ok em lúc
mà em tắm xong chắc là anh cũng off có
thể thế để xem tôi sẽ học thêm ngày sau
nữa. Tôi không bùng đâu mấy không yên
tâm.
Ờ
complier xóa thông tin này thành avelist
trong buy code. Ơ đây ông vừa nói này
đúng không
hả? Ông vừa tắm vừa xem tôi á nó hơi bị
kiểu
không được sạch sẽ lắm à. Đâu không nó
sạch sẽ không nhỉ? không được cho thoải
mái đi. Đấy kiểu thế lúc tắm là lúc mà
tôi đúng lúc tắm tôi có thỉnh thoảng hồi
trước là hồi trước nhá cái này lại hơi
đi xa một tí hô trước là tôi
à
hồi mà đi dậy đặc biệt là hồi đấy còn à
nhận dậy kiểu
nhận dậy lại xong rồi có thư tôi ngày
nào tôi cũng ngồi nghe mở một loạt video
của các thầy dạy các thứ thứ
Tắm cũng ngồi nghe à ăn cũng ngồi nghe
để mà xem các d thầy dạy mọi thứ như thế
nào để mà tham khảo về cách dạy cũng như
là kiến thức các thứ để xem là kiến thức
thầy chia sẻ nó dễ hiểu hay khó hiểu,
chỗ nào mình xúc nghiệm này cũng như là
cái gì hay thì mình học hỏi này các thứ
thứ đấy
nghe nghe các bạn nghe có thể tưởng nghĩ
là đấy thời đầu tôi đi dạy Không, ngay
gần đây luôn, ngay năm ngoái luôn tôi đi
dạy tôi cũng như thế luôn. Đấy, thì ông
sẽ biết được là à năm ngoái đúng không
nhỉ? Ừ, sang năm rồi phải năm kia chứ.
Ừ. Nghĩa là à thôi năm ngoái cũng có.
Hồi mà tôi dạy tin ở cho cho bên tuyển
sinh 247 cũng có. Nghĩa là lúc mà tôi đi
dậy là lúc mà tôi trau dồi lại kiến
thức.
Tôi a tôi trau dồi mọi lúc luôn. Bởi vì
lúc tắm là lúc mà mình đang cũng đang
thoải mái mà đúng không? Đấy nên là mình
cũng
vào đầu được. Thực ra là vào đầu được ở
đây không phải vào đầu được toàn bộ kiến
thức đâu. Vì chuẩn là mình vẫn nên có gì
đó nhìn vào mình bởi vì đôi khi có cái
gì minh họa vân vân vân. Nhưng ý tôi là
chủ yếu là tôi nghe vẫn thiên về việc và
người cách người ta nói chuyện và cách
người ta dạy hơn là về kiến thức của
người ta dạy thật. Trừ khi kiến thức
người ta chia sẻ hay quá lúc đấy nó
khác. Hồi trước là tôi nhớ là đặc biệt
là cái thời đầu tôi mới nghe tôi muốn
dạy về AI ấy thì thời đầu tôi nghe
bởi vì tôi đi làm tôi động AI đâu đúng
không? Nên tôi càm phải cùng cố kiến
thức vii để tôi còn dạy một tí gọi là
dạy tí qua môn tin học lớp 12 AI là gì
thôi. Đấy thì tôi nghe bên ach kênh là
kênh a cú thông thái à
cú thông thái thì phải. Cha phát
YouTube
ây ái ây ai cú thông ai chung tình được
mãi
video này luôn này đây rất hay rất hay
cho dù về sau thì có một tí thiên hướng
ông đấy là kiểu vẫn có tí không không
nói lùa gà gì cả nhá ông đấy vẫn có tí
là kêu gọi mọi người vào chơi tiền ảo
hay mọi thứ hay đầu tư chứng khoán hay
gì gì đó, thậm chí đầu tư vào kiểu đầu
tư hay mọi thứ gì đó thì
tôi không khuyên anh em tham gia với cái
đấy. Tôi không thể khuyên được. Tôi
khuyên khác gì bảo tôi lùa cùng. Nhưng
mà đấy thì còn nghe người ta nói rất hay
thật
chơi suông thì chán cần có gì nghe. Ok.
Xong rồi lại giống tôi hồi trước nghĩ ra
tao vừa chơi game tao vừa làm thêm một
cái gì đó cảm thấy có ích nữa. Suy ra
trung quy tao vẫn kiểu làm gì có xí chứ
không phải là chỉ chơi game lãng phí
thời gian cũng rất là hay.
Giờ tắm anh nghe gì thế hả? Tắm à? Anh
sẽ nghe nhạc.
Nghe nhạc của anh thì nhảy đủ thể loại
hôm trước nghe vừa tắm vừa nghe.
Không biết mấy ông thế nào nhưng mà tôi
kiểu thỉnh thoảng nghe nhạc không lời
thoải mái được. Kiểu mọi giờ cũng được
ấy. Nghĩa là trong làm việc vẫn nghe
nhạc không lời được. Trong mốc tắm vẫn
nghe nhạc không đời được, lúc ngủ cũng
nghe nhạc không lời được. Nghĩa là nó
không khiến cho mình buồn ngủ trừ khi
mình thực sự muốn. Đấy kiểu thế. Nhưng
nhiều người nghe nhạc không lời họ sẽ
bảo rất buồn ngủ. Đấy kiểu thế.
Em vừa tắm vừa nghe. OP đợt em xem của
anh học lập trình cùng nam. Hình như
mình biết anh đấy hoặc là anh tương tự
phải có anh anh cũng a anh đấy là anh a
nam dạy lập trình về dnet đúng không?
Nam lập trình
hướng dạy về lập trình mà. Đây đây đúng
đúng đúng rồi lập trình cùng nam đúng
rồi tôi cũng có theo dõi nhưng tôi chưa
xem mấy đâu. Kiểu lưu lưu nhiều nhưng mà
kiểu à đúng rồi mình học Java hình như
anh này cũng có dạy phải chứ nhớ mang
màng thế dạy về can code thì chắc là có
đây lập trình hướng đối tượng này không
biết có
không biết có Java hay anh ấy dạy cho
lại dnet
khóa này mình lại cùng nhau học cái đấy
à nhưng mà tôi không mở cho mấy ông xem
được nhiều lúc tôi nghĩ là tôi muốn mở
mở một cái video nào đó cùng mấy ông xem
nhưng mà cứ sợ dính bản quyền hay gì đó
nên là hơi hơi khó không ạ? Kể cả dù
người ta không đánh gậy mình nhá nhưng
biết đâu đấy nên là thôi cay thật giờ g
muốn xem thậm chí là đôi khi là tôi muốn
xem phim cùng mấy ông à kiểu chúng ta
ngồi xem phim cùng bàn luận cùng nhau
vui vui
quay lại học anh ngâu tám ít thôi
cái này để mà giao lưu chủ yếu mà
không thể tạo gen array
nữa. Chắc là cái này tôi đọc cho biết
thôi chứ về sau không thể nhớ được.
trước tôi còn nghe cái quả em tôi so
sánh kiểu Java 8 với Java 23 hay gì rồi.
Ui tôi nghĩ là tôi chưa lên được cái tầm
phải có nhớ được từng phiên bản ra hay
mọi thứ r nó khác biệt nhau nào. Tôi
dùng PP đủ lâu từ thời 5.6 đến bây giờ.
Tôi cũng phải hơi choáng về cái quả mà
kiểu có nhiều cái đến bây giờ có những
cái mới ra bây giờ mình cũng chưa dùng
ấy. Đấy nhưng ít ra tôi biết được lịch
sử của nó. Chứ giờ vả tôi ngồi học thêm
lịch sử Java mà Java còn dày hơn chịu
là cái elite này nó chỉ chứa object nó
là class object chứ không nên chứa kiểu
nguyên thủy là kiểu kiểu như này được
đúng không ạ? Nghĩa là bồ lại thì cái
này sẽ có nun được đúng không? Hay có
một array toàn nun được không? Kiểu in
nhưng mà toàn nun được đúng không? Tôi
nghĩ là được.
rồi tôi không để ý quả extend này. Đấy.
biết à hàm xăm này vừa rồi tự viết à tôi
cứ tưởng là có một cái hàm riêng tên là
xăm cơ. Lỗi tôi
hỏi chấm này không nói này nhưng mà tend
này khai báo
phải là một là number. Number ở đây sẽ
có cả integer hoặc là flat đúng không?
super.
cái này mấy ông có dùng thường xuyên
không vậy? Nhìn cái này rõ ràng là
rõ ràng là nó kiểu nó có chặt chẽ nhưng
mà nó lại hơi lỏng nhở. Nó nó lá giống
như kiểu ở trong a PP nó sẽ khái niệm là
tha như mà tha mic ấy đúng không? Mấy
không biết không?
này kiểu có có thể nhiều cái kiểu một
lúc ấy. Cái này không hẳn đến mức độ đấy
nhưng mà nó sẽ là không một cái hai cụ
thể nữa. Nó sẽ kết thừa hay gì gì đó.
Ừ cái này nó sẽ vẫn có tí thiên hướng về
các class nhỉ. Uầy thế này tôi vừa nãy
tôi đang nói là nó tường minh theo kiểu
tường minh theo kiểu là IDE có thể g ý
các thứ thứ thứ đúng không? Ngồi đập
đúng này xong tôi không nghĩ là nào gợi
ý nổi. Trừ khi là à không chắc là chuyên
về Java giống như là mấy ông bảo tôi
dùng cái gì nhỉ? Cái pin Java nào nhỉ?
Quên mất rồi. Thì mấy cái con đấy chuyên
nó có compiler chạy các thứ thứ thì chắc
là nó vẫn sẽ gợi ý được thôi. Đấy nhưng
mà
chắc là phải làm mới nhớ được. À không
làm chưa chắc nhớ. Phải dùng từ như nào
nhỉ?
Chẳng biết như nào vào dự án thực tế.
điều
kiểu đặt ra dấu vào chấm list này tôi
vừa rồi tôi hiểu rồi nên tôi xóa đi. Ok.
Đấy nghĩa là lúc đầu mình có thể thắc
mắc nhưng mà đến cuối mình hiểu được thì
chứng tỏ mình hiểu được bài đúng không
ạ? Đấy hôm trước à hôm qua tôi nói
chuyện nhiều quá rồi thành ra là chưa
kịp học gì đ không ạ. Hôm nay tôi sẽ học
bù cả ngày thứ năm ngày thứ sáu đấy.
Được không ạ?
phải nói được không ạ? Nhưng mà thực ra
là được hay không thì tôi vẫn là người
quyết định mà.
không không cần các mốc các thứ mình
không học phải các mốc lỗi run time ơ
trong này còn không có
là nhầm cái
Đúng rồi mà
trước Java
lệch ấy đúng không?
có Z với sve nhỉ?
bịa ra đấy.
linh hoạt hai safety cũng được.
đây.
ảnh đầu luôn thì phải.
biết LSP nói viết tắt của gì đâu nhá.
Thì thằng con kế thừa thằng cha thì
thằng con cũng phải được như thằng cha.
Câu này bữa phỏng vấn nó phê xíu.
những cái thằng cha làm việc gì thằng
con nó cũng sẽ phải làm được và hơn thế.
Đấy, tôi nhớ là như thế. Nó là kiểu
extend là cái thư cái thế
hơn thế được không đúng lắm nhưng mà nó
chỉ nó có thể custom được ấy. Nhưng mà
gần như là thằng cha làm được gì, thằng
con cũng phải làm được. Đấy.
ngày thứ sáu đúng không ạ?
ta đã đến interface. Xin chúc mừng ạ.
Check class. Tôi
tôi nghĩ sau buổi thứ sáu này được. Tôi
nghĩ là tôi sẽ
à cứ cho là gần cái cái mục này quan
trọng đi. Tôi sẽ
bảo AI tạo ra một bài
một một loạt các bài phỏng vấn
tầm
20 câu hỏi đi. 20 câu hỏi về hôm trước
tôi có nói mấy ông. Mấy ông nhớ chứ?
Chắc mấy ông có thể mấy ông chưa xem cái
video hôm trước. 20 câu hỏi. Ừ 20 câu
hỏi đi. Chúng ta ngồi chơi ca hút
được không ạ?
Ừ. Nhưng mà ca hút không ổn nhỉ? Tôi
biết đáp án à? Cũng không? Tôi bảo ai
soạn và làm sao cho để ừ tôi dùng thằng
tôi bảo ai soạn rồi bảo ông em tôi hoặc
là bảo bạn bạn tôi ngồi nói chung ngồi
soạn câu hỏi rồi anh em mình sẽ ngồi
chơi cao hút với nhau được chứ. Đây mình
sẽ ngồi chơi cao hút với nhau để
trả lời mấy cái đống từ buổi thứ một cho
đến buổi thứ sáu này.
20 thật ra còn ít đấy. Buổi sáu buổi mà
đúng không? Mỗi buổi ba câu. Ừ thật ra
thế không ít lắm nhỉ? Ừ mày không hiểu
chứ. Nhưng cái riêng interface abcheck
class này tôi nghĩ là sẽ phải hỏi nhiều
nhất
nhá. Mấy ông biết ca hút rồi đúng không
ạ? Đấy chúng ta sẽ ngồi chơi nhá. Thắng
có qua không?
Anh anh đang định nhờ em bảo ngồi em
soạn câu hỏi mà em định chơi cùng à?
Đấy,
à. Nhưng mà nếu mà em hỏi thằng có quà
không cho người khác thì ok.
À tôi cho là
quà bây giờ nên là gì nhỉ?
Nếu mà tốt cho anh em thì sẽ là như nào
nhỉ? Ừ, chẳng lẽ em bảo một tháng dùng
ai gì đó kiểu
có chứ. Có qua cho anh em thắng chắc nó
s nhỉ. Ờ nhưng mà không không biết mấy
ông em chắc mấy chắc anh em ở đây đều
xanh chín thôi. Chắc không anh em nào
hack khủng chơi bẩn đâu. Vì tôi nhớ
trước ca hood có cái vụ là có thể hack
được. Chắ bây giờ nó cũng fix rồi. Ờ qua
chắc là bạn top ba người thì sẽ
thực ra top 3 thì cả ba người đều như
nhau cho dễ nhá.
được 1 tháng dùng AI đi.
AI bây giờ sẽ
AI bây giờ đắt nhất thì con nào nhỉ?
Thường là AI toàn là
như nào?
Cái key cáp hôm trước á? Không káp thôi.
Ừ
anh em kiểu gì bây giờ vai code dùng ai
mà bây giờ đầu tư cho anh em một tháng
kiểu 10 đô. 10 đô là tầm hơn 200 hoặc là
15 đô tầm đấy. Ai bây giờ toàn 10 15 đô
thôi mà đúng không? Đấy, tầm đây để anh
em dùng AI chúng ta sẽ ngồi vai code
với nhau cũng một kiểu. Thế là tôi chưa
nghĩ cái giải thưởng đâu. Tôi tôi sẽ tạo
một cái à một cái thở ở trên a
à gọi là th đi giống voer một cái thớt ở
trên Discord server Discord để anh em có
gì cùng thảo luận nhá. để xem là nên có
giải mọi thứ như nào và nên có thời gian
nữa để thông báo thời gian anh em để anh
em cùng chuẩn bị. Đấy chúng ta mục tiêu
của tôi đó là cũng phải tầm ít nhất ít
nhất là cũng tầm 20 người tham gia cao
hút cho nó sâ tự nhiên có năm người chơi
thì ba người thắng thì trông nó hơi bị
buồn cười đúng không ạ
nhỉ? Mà không thấy hợp lý đúng không?
Không phản đối tức là đồng ý nhá. Ok
lại cái mấy cái này đăng lên server cho
mấy ông là bây giờ mấy ông còn đang chưa
xem hoặc là xem lại sau đúng không?
tiếng ma đi dậy xong rồi 20 câu mình trả
lời được. Chưa đến năm câu thì chắc là
mình cũng xấu hổ lắm.
N không sao chơi quan trọng là chơi cùng
anh em cho vui vì rõ ràng là đấy đấy là
một cách để kết nối thôi vì rõ ràng anh
em ở đây có nhiều người không ở Hà Nội
tôi cũng chưa gặp bao giờ các thứ thứ
đây một cách để chúng ta sẽ có cơ hội để
mà một cách kết nối một cách giao lưu gì
đó không trực tiếp
xếp tôi thường anh đặt interface tên là
contract thì gì đó.
Và object class
base template. Uầy, đọc thế này dễ hiểu
hơn hẳn luôn ý. Ồ, đấy mấy ông đọc cái
kiểu như này một phát hiểu ngay chăng.
Không biết là mấy ông có hiểu cái này
không? Tôi hiểu đấy. Kiểu hiểu nó kiểu
rằng buộc thôi. Nó kiểu rằng kiểu phải
cần có những cái gì thôi. Còn B template
thì đấy nó là cái kiểu cái gốc là gì.
Thì xong rồi mình sẽ kéo như nào đấy.
Bọn tôi thường hay đặt tên kiểu như này
cơ t vẫn dùng cái này nhên vẫn dùng rồi
nhưng mà đặt tên kiểu này.
Đa hình đa hình này xong rồi đa gì nữa
tôi quên mất rồi. Tí xem
object class
bắt buộc phải dùng element. Đúng rồi.
Kiểu khai bái kiểu như này là khi mà
khai báo check là bắt buộc phải khai báo
cái method đấy đúng không? Mic sao? Húp
húp meo meo spit.
cả C hay là dog slip chắc giống nhau
đúng không? Interface behavior là có
những cái a thói quen một cái thuốc tính
riêng.
mặt. Nó chư quan tâm thứ này có thể trả
tiền. Payment method đúng
đúng bâ tôi gọi một khái niệm payment
method pay này pay này interface cùng
chung một cái những cái chung contract
cam kết sẽ làm được việc này đấy mọi
field bắt buộc mặc định là public static
final
là nó là kiểu chỉ được kiểu
mình phải khai báo kiểu còng overrive
này đúng không khái niệm override ghi đè
các thứ này đúng
có bắt buộc không?
Chắc là bây giờ giờ này mấy ông đang
ngồi ăn mết rồi hoặc đang đi chơi. Bây
giờ đến giờ đi chơi mà đúng không? 8:00
8 gi bắt đầu lên đồ lên 3. Đấy hôm trước
tôi thường mới nói như thế
đấy.
Mọi mặc định là public attract. Ừ.
Xong rồi.
À cái field này đây đúng không? Fở trong
trường hợp này nó là attribute à đúng
không?
Public order này.
được nhỉ? Tôi chưa hiểu cái này. À nó
contractor à
ồ cách contractor trong này nó khác với
trong VP khá là rõ. Không biết được là
tí nếu mà convert sang bên Java thì sẽ
Ừ tôi tôi biết final là không thể thay
đổi được rồi.
Ơ nhưng mà nếu thế sẽ
trường hợp này nó chính là cái này rồi
đúng không? F chính attribute rồi. Đối
với tôi hiểu cái này là attribute
không thể thay đổi đúng không ạ?
À
cái gì gì đó này
sẽ notốe lại đây.
số nữa.
lắm. Chắc là phải làm mới hiểu
đâu. Đầu tiên thanh toán 100 này. Thanh
toán theo dùng cái nào? Up check khi
quan hệ cha con chặt chẽ. khi class
không liên quan nhưng có chung hành
động. Ừm, cái này hợp lý hơn này.
Tuy là nó dễ hiểu. Cái này tôi từng
biết, tôi học hồi Java rồi nhưng mà với
tôi thế này là chưa đủ để mà rõ hơn. Tôi
sẽ
tôi sẽ yêu cầu
thêm AI bắt nó làm chặt hơn cái này.
Ờ
cho tôi
thêm
ví dụ chặt chẽ
hơn để hiểu make practice
khi nào dùng
contract
interface
và trả lời cho tôi
đấy.
thì mình sẽ bắt phải kỹ hơn đúng không
ạ? Thế cái này thực ra là tôi biết cái
này tôi biết mà cái cái mấy cái này tôi
thường hợp Java tôi biết rồi cái
interface rồi cả thì nó cũng lấy ví dụ
là chó mèo như này rồi cái order thì
thấy còn mới thôi.
example này.
dùng khi class quan hệ cho con chia sẻ
code chung full time employee. Đây là
employee đúng chung các thứ thứ đúng
không? Còn cái này là có thể làm được
gì? Dùng cho class không liên quan đến
nhau nhưng trung hành vi đấy. Behavior
đúng không? Trung hành vi
thuế. Ok.
liên kết lọc
không liên quan không quan tâm đối tượng
employee các thứ thứ chỉ quan tâm đối
tượng có à ok qu
cái này sẽ phải khai báo một cái tex
service ở dưới đúng không là một class
bình thường là đóng thuế
chấp nhận nạp vào cái gì đó không phụ
thuộc vào full time emp hay company sau
này nếu freeland hay robot nộp thuế cái
này hàm này sẽ không cần sửa đúng viết
kiểu này nó sẽ kiểu tường minh ấy nó
kiểu tách tách ra thì rõ ràng là về sau
code kiểu gì sẽ có mở rộng thêm đúng
không code càng rõ cái này nó không kiểu
không phụ thuộc vào cái kia thì mình chỉ
cần sửa một chỗ những chỗ khác nó vẫn
chạy được đấy đây châm nghiệm của tôi.
Tìm hiểu thêm về contter mặc định với
conter có tham số nữa anh em. Ok. Hay là
tôi sẽ
Tôi nghĩ là thỉnh thoảng có mấy ông nói
như này nhưng mà tôi chưa có chỗ nào để
ghi. Tôi sẽ tạo một cái file ở đây đi.
Tôi nghĩ tạo file đây là file à không
phải tại file đây.
Đâu rồi?
ra nó không phải MD đâu. Đó nên là
text hiểu được là mình sẽ có một câu nào
đó
Đấy, thc có mà tôi bấm vào tại vừa rồi
lười chứ. Đấy bấm vào đây tôi có chỉnh
rồi mà bấm vào nó nhảy. Tôi tôi vừa rồi
trong trường hợp vừa rồi tôi muốn xem nó
nhắc đến ở đ những đâu nữa đấy chứ thực
ra là tôi tôi có tôi có chỉnh cho VS
code bấm vào để nhảy đến cụ thể rồi.
class lắm.
Chắc là về sau tôi sẽ viết ru ở trong
này luôn không cho nó tạo class. Tôi
viết ru thêm một vài cái nữa.
12 buổi nên chắc là về sau tôi sẽ xóa
sau nhá. Về sau cái gì tôi sẽ xóa này.
Cái này không cần nữa.
Ơ vừa rồi bay mất cái tôi vừa xóa mất
cái B practice đúng không?
này,
thuế này. Ồ hay phết đa hình này hợp lý
hợp lý hợp lý. Interface khả năng bất kỳ
ai cũng phải tính toán nụp thuế đúng
không? Đấy nhân viên này logic chung gộp
lại các thứ thứ đây. Khai báo kiểu đối
tượng các thứ thứ. Ok. Đoạn tôi hiểu.
Xong rồi implement cái interface. Ok.
Xong rồi còn phải định nghĩa cách tính
lương. Mỗi người có thể định nghĩa cách
tính lương khác nhau. Ồ cái này cũng là
object class. À đây kết hợp cả hai dùng
cả object và dùng cả interface đúng
không? Hay phết. Đấy tiếp theo là thằng
này kế thừa cái employee vừa rồi này.
Full time employee. Đấy gọi super. Tôi
nhớ tôi nhớ cái cái đoạn này rồi. Super
này là gọi đến thằng tra đúng không? Đấy
khai báo thằng cha đúng không? Chính là
cái trường hợp này. Ok.
Ok. Bắt buộc
không vintax được khuyên dùng có để
tránh lỗi. Ok. Ok. Khai báo ra chắc là
để cho thằng IDE gợi ý ý nó chuẩn đúng
không? Đấy đấy. Ok là khai báo kiểu trả
về cái mly các thứ thứ như nào tính
thuế. cũng ghi đè cái hàm cái hàm thuế
này từ tch từ interface đấy.
list new array list là
một implement nó tương tự set có
tret đúng không và hasset đúng set thì
tôi có nghe tret và hasset thử ra chưa
chưa chưa học đến bên đấy không biết là
có đề cập không nên tôi cứ tạm nốt lại
đây nhá tr set và hset
đâ này nhá. Đấy.
khai báo nhưng không được dùng ở đâu cả
đúng không?
lên này. Cái này kế thừa thẳng cái in
interface kia luôn không cần kế thừa
thằng employee nữa đúng không?
get mari này.
À bởi vì mình đang chưa có tạo một cái
thằng nữa. Ví dụ ở thằng tên là P time
Time
Employee đúng không? Nếu tạo thêm một
thằng PH time employee nữa thì get Money
Sari này có thể chỉ giảm một nửa thôi
đúng không? Nó hợp lý.
time. Đ thử tạo nhá.
Đấy
như này đi thì nó sẽ dễ hình dung hơn vì
tự nhiên mất công tạo một thằng full
time có một hàm trông chỉ trả về
đúng chính nó thì nó không kiểu không
điểm gì.
Theo tôi thì thấy thế thường là phải có
lý do một cái gì đó đương nhiên là get
set đôi khi chúng ta trả về thẳng luôn
đấy như tôi muốn nói lại thêm là có thể
là mình custom lại nó đúng không? Hợp lý
mà đúng không?
Ok, đoạn này dễ hiểu đấy. Rồi. Ờ,
dựa vào các file vừa thay đổi
ghi rõ đi bởi vì tôi vừa giờ sửa nhiều
file
vừa thay rồi.
Sửa lại đây
Sau chúng ta sẽ tạo ra cái file doc.
Uây, chưa gì mình đã học xong bài thứ
sáu rồi. Cũng nhanh nhỉ. Nhanh tôi thấy
là nhanh đấy.
Interface và object.
này không không hề nó chỉ là một cái nhỏ
thôi mình không nên cho nó vào mình thực
ra mình chỉ quan tâm đến
can do
is a này kiểu kiểu so sánh hai bên như
này hợp lý
lầm là
gọi như này
chỉ được kế thừa kiểu
chỉ có một parent thôi đúng không? Tất
cả kiểu ví dụ là kiểu con thì sẽ chỉ có
mỗi extend một cha thôi đúng không? Đấy
xong rồi. À đương nhiên cha cũng thể
extend nữa kiểu ông hay các tự thứ đúng
không nhở?
Để tôi hỏi lại
cái này
sửa luôn trong đốc à? À thôi cứ hỏi lại
đây đi.
À trong Java
chỉ
được à class
một
tra
par thôi đúng không?
thêm
còn
interface
thì
được nhiều
không hay nó ngồi sửa code của mình.
Đúng rồi bạn ơi.
bây giờ là sẽ là
đúng rồi ông cháu ơi. Chẳng hạn đấy
đơn gọi là đơn cái thừa đúng không?
Th là trong PP thì các cũng thế thôi
nhưng mà tôi không nhớ về PP về cái vụ
interface lắm. Tôi chưa vụ tôi thường
chỉ dùng chỉ cũng gọi là implement
à đâu có một vài job một vài cái th liên
quan đến job của thằng Laurel là có cái
implement nhiều interface rồi không nhớ
cái đấy lắm như nghĩa là cái đấy là
class viết sẵn của framework chứ bình
thường mình viết thì mình sẽ chỉ kế thừa
mình tạo một interface thôi xong mình kế
thừa
à đây Không phải kế thừa nhỉ? Nó dùng từ
như nào nhỉ?
hàng phải tự viết nên không sợ nhầm lẫn.
Cái này à bên này không có chết nhỉ?
Đúng không? Bên Java
là một cái hàm thể dùng chung.
nhật tính default method. Đấy.
à. Đấy đấy
đây là Java mấy? Java 8 cộng đôi lên.
Ok. Thế nó cũng giống nóng tí giống chết
ở bên PP nhưng mà nó là theo interface
không truyền biến vào đúng không?
hoạch cho anh em buổi
buổi sau hơi quá nhưng mà tôi sẽ lên kế
hoạch và sẽ báo anh em để chốt một hôm
mình sẽ ngồi làm thử bài trắc nghiệm ca
hút. Có thể 20 câu có thể ngắn hơn không
biết được. Tôi nghĩ là 20 câu tí. Đấy
anh em sẽ ngồi livestream như thế này và
trả lời. Đấy hy vọng không bị delay lắm
đấy.
Để máy anh có thể anh em có thể xem để
tránh bị delay tôi cứ tăng mỗi câu 30
giây chắc cũng thoải mái thôi. Chắc là
không đến nỗi trả lời nhanh nhanh quá
đâu. Thích thì tôi sẽ nhắm mắt xin câu
hỏi rồi nhắm mắt lại đợi hai giây trả
lời cùng mấy ông công bằng xanh chín đấy
nhở.
Đấy thì anh em ngồi trả lời xong rồi top
3 thử hình như có ừ top 3 sẽ có cái giải
thưởng nào đó xong anh em sẽ tự ngồi
thông nhất nhau giải thưởng là gì nhở
một cách cái giao lưu kết nối đầu biết
đâu đầu cầu bên kia đang tận ở c nước
ngoài hoặc là đang ở ở trong Nam ý nhân
như thế đấy anh em vẫn có cái có thể
tương tác với nhau vui nhở.
Ok thế nhá. Bây giờ tôi đi ăn đã. Mấy
ông có thể ăn rồi nhưng tôi chưaấy. Xin
chào mấy ông nhá. Tạm biệt mấy ông. Có
gì thắc mắc hay nói chuyện thêm thì
chúng ta vào Discord để nói chuyện nhé.
Xin chào mấy ông.